à partir de demain et jusqu'au 19 mars
vous allez peut-être être témoin
d'action dans les régions du québec pour
empêcher françois legault de mettre en
place les fameuses maternelle quatre ans
le conseil québécois des services
éducatifs à la petite enfance et la
fédération des intervenantes en petite
enfance du québec
là on a un mois d'action je reçois ce
matin la vice présidente de la
fédération à mélanie afficher un pichet
bonjourbonjour qu'on attend qu'est ce
que c'est au juste ces actions là à quoi
ce qu'on doit s'attendre à partir de
demain dès demain matin on débute une
première conférence de presse accompagné
du conseil québécois dans l'objectif
avec aussi madame iphone qui nous
soutient qu'ils ont appuyé notre
pétition sur le site de l'assemblée
nationale
véronique hivon oui c'est l'effet oui et
donc l'objectif en soi c'est de
sensibiliser tant nos parents la
population sur les enjeux actuels c'est
à dire le déploiement de la maternelle 4
à travers le québec de la part du
gouvernement
donc ce sont des administrateurs et des
intervenants et intervenantes en petite
enfance qui veulent faire ce genre de
manifestation exactement les
intervenants tant ces pays ainsi que les
responsables de service éducatif en
milieu familial régis subventionné
pourquoi exactement ces cas là la
principale raison qui fait en sorte que
vous vous opposez au déploiement des
maternelles quatre ans il faut se
rappeler qu'en 1997 on a mis en place un
réseau de la petite enfance au réseau
éducatif à la petite enfance qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui et il est important
de bien signifier à la population que ce
réseau de la petite enfance mon nom au
québec y en a pas partout ailleurs au
canada le canada a envie notre réseau
parce que c'était aux raisons qui ont
été mis en place avec une mission
éducative pour le développement global
du tout petit donc on croit que tous les
enfants de 0 à 5 ans doivent être dans
notre réseau parce qu'on a un objectif
deux rives cette éducation mais le
gouvernement de la côte est samedi au
québec ne veut pas substituer les cpe en
maternelle 4 ans ce sera pas obligatoire
non plus donc ça va être accessible à
tous dans toutes les régions pour des
parents auront choix ils y auront le
choix mais quel choix dans le sens où
notre réseau éducatif répond au besoin
on a un rôle de proximité auprès des
parents mais aussi auprès des enfants
un rôle d'éducation donc quand on sait
que dans note dans nos services on
répond aux besoins et on atteint
l'objectif de la réussite éducative
on doit prioriser le réseau qu'on a mis
en place sur l'important est ce que
c'est aussi alimenté par une crainte de
perte d'emploi pour vos intervenantes en
petite enfance
c'est ce qu'on s'est fait dire mais non
faut une préoccupation c'est les enfants
4 ans pourquoi parce que quand les
enfants 4 invaincu t on eu quarante
mille autres enfants qui sont dans le
réseau privé qui peut venir dans notre
réseau mais des experts je pense à égide
royer par exemple qu'indique la
maternelle 4 ans c'est bon pour les pour
les enfants ça assure une meilleure
réussite scolaire on a d'autres
cherchent comme madame j'appelle qui dit
elle au contraire que ça peut être
préoccupant parce que au niveau du ratio
par exemple ont une préoccupation sur le
ratio est important au niveau le 1,17
nous en cpe serait un sur dix en milieu
familial c'est un sur six le jeu vous je
vous nomme quelques critères mais c'est
important de se rappeler que on a établi
un réseau de la petite enfance ou les
critères les facteurs favorables pour un
développement de l'enfant ont été mis au
maximum dans notre réseau temps que moi
je suis un clown à dire que c'est notre
réseau qui répondent ses enfants dont
vous vous opposez à tout déploiement le
même si c'est pas obligatoire on est
quand à sion - cinq ans on est contre un
mur à mur mais on demeure par exemple
préoccupé qu'un enfant qui est en milieu
défavorisé ou qui ont pas encore là une
place dans notre réseau public peut-être
d'avoir une maternelle quatre ans pour
milieux défavorisés l'homme et du mur à
mur on écope donc dans les milieux
défavorisés
ça peut ça peut passer il ya eu des
sorties et public cette semaine des
présidents de commissions scolaires à
montréal sur la rive-sud également qui
disent qu'elles vont manquer de locaux
qu'elles ne pourront pas mettre en place
ce système là est-ce que ça ça vient
renforcer votre mouvement ce que ça vous
donne vie au point dans vos arguments
bain en effet sont pas capables de
répondre à l'objectif
et quand on sait que des gens réseau de
la petite enfance public qui existent
ballon investir dans notre réseau qu'on
ait mis en place et donc on est si fier
et que le canada en vie donc comment ça
se passe à partir de demain on commence
notre conférence lundi matin joliette et
on en a une autre à laval en après-midi
et ensuite on fait le tour du québec
la niche et vice président de la
fédération des intervenantes en petite
enfance du québec merci beaucoup
[Musique]